qu'elle soit individuelle collective au
mondial les trajectoires façonnent nos
sociétés et nos histoires
une thématique prise à son sens large
pour une exposition ludique et
interactive
l'objectif de cette exposition c'est
d'interroger les gens c'est de mobiliser
un peu leur questionnement sur qu'est-ce
que c'est se déplacer qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que c'est vivre dans une ville
et dans quel monde vit-on
et quels sont les impacts de la 2d de
tous ses déplacements à l'échelle de
notre planète découvrir la mobilité de
son corps à l'aide d'une balance qui
identifie le point reposant sur chacune
de ses jambes ou bien les trajectoires
des mots et du langage
mais alors en fait dans cet extrait ci
vous avez l'oreille vous avez peut-être
entendu le monde mayonnaise qui a été
incorporé dans la langue japonaise
l'exposition entre dans le projet
question société et enjeux citoyens de
la région ile de france
elle restitue des travaux de chercheurs
mais aussi de groupes de citoyens en
collaboration avec huit associations de
médiation scientifique une par
département la médiation scientifique en
fait c'est l'idée de pouvoir apporter
aux citoyens
le maximum d'informations sur des
questions de science pour qu'ensuite ils
puissent faire leurs propres choix
construire leur propre opinion
ouverte au grand public les mercredi et
samedi puis du lundi au vendredi à
partir des vacances scolaires vous
pourrez même y planter votre fleur de
mobilité à chaque pétale une
caractéristique de vos propre
trajectoire et ensuite je suis invité à
la pause et là où j'ai envie d'aller
je vais la mettre pour cette fois oh
on nous que je me trompe pas au japon si
ça rentre voilà et avant de partir au
japon pouvait circuler à l'espace
exposition de l'île de loisirs les
vestiaires de l'ancienne piscine ont
même été utilisé pour y découvrir
l'infographie et photographies